so it's a beautiful day and I have the
great privilege of not being stuck in an
office or working otherwise in a stuffy
cubicle somewhere instead I'm here in
waffled Park Ealing enjoying the Sun
trying not to get pooed on by birds I
did already get peed on by a bird I am
actually working I'm collecting b-roll
for a video I'm making and I thought
this to be a good opportunity to talk
about a topic I find very interesting
called lifestyle design which is all
about you know being able to work in the
environment that you enjoy and making
your work fits around your lifestyles
instead of the other way around so let's
talk about that shall we
so what is lifestyle design well I
basically literally just told you if you
were listening you would know I said it
was fitting your work around your
lifestyle instead of your lifestyle
around your work so typically we try and
find a job we feel very privileged to
have found whatever job we were
fortunate to get and then we move to
whatever location we need to move to in
order to do that job or we just fit our
lifestyle around that routine there's a
couple sort of really getting it on over
there this a little bit distracting
sorry
so we fit our routine basically around
our work and that means often not only
going to work boss of commuting to and
from work and then having only a few
hours in the evening in which to spend
our free time and feeling naked so the
alternative to this is to flip the idea
on its head instead you think what does
the lifestyle I want and what's the job
that will support that lifestyle so to a
lot of people this means becoming a
digital nomad and a digital nomad is
someone who travels the world was
working on the laptop they work online
and this enables them to work them
anywhere as long as they have a plug and
Wi-Fi which most places in the world
these days do so they can travel to
across Europe across America or wherever
sitting cafes during the day typing away
and then in evenings go and explore or
vice versa and to them that's like the
pinnacle of what they want to do at that
time and they believe they've achieved
freedom etc from that and to a lot of
people the idea of being a digital nomad
and lifestyle design they're synonymous
however if you only focus on being a
digital nomad you're kind of missing the
point because lifestyle design is about
building the lifestyle you want and that
might not mean travelling all the time
for me traveling all the time would be a
little bit much I would miss my creature
comforts like cups of tea and comics on
a Wednesday and I also have a wife and
I'd probably miss her an awful lot and
so in general it doesn't really suit me
to be constantly traveling around the
globe I like to travel a little bit more
than your average and fortunately my job
affords me that but I also just like to
have a more laid-back lifestyle instead
of commuting to work like still work out
in the morning I like to sit in coffee
shops around London or visit um nice
locations and I like the privilege to
come and be able to work somewhere like
this and do things that I really enjoy
like working on projects like this video
other videos my website my apps and I
get a lot more reward from that so I
thought what's the lifestyle I want
and that is the lifestyle of the pioneer
and then I thought how do I make this
happen instead of thinking I'm gonna do
this job right now how do I make my life
work around that and working online
isn't the only way to do this in fact
the only way anything you need to do is
to realize that there are lots of ways
to achieve your goals and you need to
know what your goals are so a lot of
people they work towards this invisible
end point where they're going to retire
and have this amazing life but do you
really want to wait until you retired to
actually start living life I say no and
I think so should you instead it makes
more sense to try and live the life you
want now and I think actually for most
of us we have the means to have the
lifestyle that we want already within
our grasp so for instance if you want to
travel more what I do is I got on cheap
holidays easy easy jet and I'm fortunate
to have a friend pilot meaning I can get
extra for cheap flights but to be honest
a flight to Europe for me cost the same
as visiting my home in Bournemouth so
it's negligible the fact that I can work
online means that I can work as I go I
means I have to take time off work it
also means that when I want to take time
off work or after asking on submission
and I can go away for three or four days
at time stay with a friend maybe or
visit somewhere stay in an air B&B very
cheaply there's no reason for me not to
travel as much as I like and you can
probably do the same thing your work
might be more flexible than you realize
if you ask about taking a little bit of
time off or perhaps working from home
then taking your laptop with you to
another country they're not going to
know so yeah you can travel more and
have what you want or perhaps what you
want is a massive house well that's fine
all you have to do is put your resources
that you already have into that massive
house so instead of trying to earn more
and more money instead to try and
increase your wealth by changing the way
you spend your money because here's the
other tip your wealth is not directly
tied to your income for starters you can
have more than one income I make money
from my writing from videos from my
website from apps but if you've got a
full time job you can also decide to cut
people's hair or rent out a room on
Airbnb or to students you know there's
this whole sharing economy thing you
could decide to sell crafts on eBay what
I'm saying is there's no reason that you
have to think I have to get a promotion
after work harder to get more money
that's actually often a lot of other
ways to get money and sometimes it just
means spending less money on things you
don't really need like I know that I buy
computer games sometimes before I finish
playing the other game I just bought
Bastion and I bought transistor because
those games were on
she'll offer on Steam but I haven't
finished playing Fury yet so why did I
do that I don't know but if you stopped
doing that sort of thing and you stopped
spending money in the places you don't
need it you'll have more to spend money
on things you want so again it's just
know your goal and knowing what it is
you want to achieve and then once you do
that you might realize that actually the
easiest way for you to get what you want
the lifestyle you want even if that's
just spending more time with your family
might be to work as a dustbin collector
because then you're finished early in
the day actually surprisingly well-paid
and it's a stable income and maybe you
don't need that much more money you
realize to do the things you want to do
so instead of working harder and harder
and thinking the anywhere can spend more
time with my family is conversely to
work harder and longer hours you just
think actually what is the easiest way
to get to where I want to go instead of
shooting for the stars because you never
know what's around the corner instead of
aiming for the light at the end of the
tunnel make it happen now and work out
what the best way to make that happen is
another tip is that you can be whatever
you want to be without means to sound
too much like a cheesy car bumper
sticker you can be whatever you want to
be right now it's only being hard no
that's wrong you can be whatever you
want to be right now it's only been good
that's the hard bit so for instance if
you want to be a famous music artist
that's hard but if you wanna be a music
artist that's easy all you have to do is
start recording music in your spare time
so for instance my sister she is an
artist she did an art degree and instead
of focusing on becoming an artist
because she realized that the path of an
artist is a hard one she's actually now
a saleswoman and she works on her art in
her spare time and she gets just as much
pleasure out of that that that she would
from doing it as her main job so she can
earn her money come home and then work
on her projects in a kind of more
relaxed atmosphere and she just sell
them and she doesn't make some money on
the side she's doing living a dream but
she's also doing a job the two things
don't need to be Wed to one another
another way if you wanted to become a
famous music artist perhaps instead of
working really hard and trying to get
noticed by a record label create your
own YouTube channel and start sharing
music on there as soon as you start
doing that playing you're on track to
being the thing you want to be and even
if you never quite accomplished it
you'll still get that sense of reward in
the sense of progress that comes just
from doing it because I get so much
reward out doing this channel even
though this video will probably get a
hundred views I don't care I love doing
it and the biennium and you know and
I don't know what that means I don't why
I did in American accent but the point
is I'm having fun and it doesn't
necessarily have to be tied to your
career the way I've achieved the
lifestyle I want which is to wake up a
bit later go to the gym or work out from
home work in a coffee shop and then work
on my own projects until my wife gets
home and then have a chill evening
whoever achieved that is to work online
and that was also what gives me the
freedom to travel a bit more etc but
that doesn't have to be your path if you
are interested in working online now
we'll be making more videos on this I'm
personally a writer a freelance writer
and I've also extended into a couple of
other areas like videos and also app
creation of course and I've made a video
on app creation and I'll talk a bit
about how I work as a writer it's
actually very easy I posted three
adverts and it's given me work for seven
years so I'll tell you how I did that
and you can do the same thing in a
future video but for now the lifestyle
design instead of thinking about what's
my job and how to make my life work
around it think about what's the
lifestyle I want and what job is the
best way to get there and it might
surprise you what the answer is
think of it outside the box so yes a
little bit of ramble but I hope you
found it interesting and useful if you
want more about lifestyle design I
highly recommend the book the 4-hour
workweek by Tim Ferriss he pretty much
coined the phrase and yeah good luck
with it if you enjoyed this video please
like share and subscribe and I'll see
you for the next one which could be
about me kopecks fitness productivity
technology who knows but it's always
about action self-development and yeah
see you then and thanks very much for
watching bye for now